mag jetzt die fotos und schluss ist
[Musik]
in den in den stock hat stoppt bevor wir
mit diesem video anfang leute sollte ich
glaube ich vor waren das was wir heute
in diesem video sehen werdet könnt ihr
euch akut die lust am leben nehmen denn
wir schauen uns heute an wieder und was
mir ein zuschauer schon vor einiger zeit
zugeschickt hat und dann dass ich mich
ehrlich gesagt bisher nicht ran getraut
habe weil der titel allein ein beschluss
gefühl gibt vielleicht sollte ich lieber
nicht drauf klicken aber sind wir ganz
ehrlich leute wir sind vielleicht nicht
immer geschlossen gewesen und letzten
endes klicken wir meistens dann doch
drauf und zwar heute darf ich euch heute
das video hier präsentieren ich muss
ehrlich zugeben allein den titel
vorzulesen bereitet mir schon auf jeden
fall diverse innere blutung der titel
lautet gerät annegret die sexbombe rtl2
family stories ist ja ich glaube ist das
so schlimm aber lotte fackelt nicht
lange herum stürzen zu den kampf ganz
großes erlebnis kommentar im letzten
video der kommt von black kick ist
revolucion und sie schreibt also wir
brandenburger leben alle in zelten ist
doch völlig normal
strom und wasser gibt es auch nicht
vielen dank dafür dass du meine anderen
bestätigt hast ähnlichen schwierigkeiten
sieht sie ihre schon kostenlos durch und
kann zumindest für sich erste erfolge
vermelden
okay leute das ist haben wir unsere
protagonistin annegret und wenn wir uns
die liebe alle gerät jetzt hier in der
ersten sekunde mal anschauen und
überlegen wie der titel dieses videos
ist dann merken wir dass das ganze schon
mal in eine grundlegend falsche richtung
geht meine einzige hoffnung jetzt sollte
es irgendwann sich diesen titel heraus
gesagt hat dass es nichts mit dem video
zu tun hat aber ich habe irgendwie so
eine böse vorahnung einmal muss ich mich
je 3 das ist doch schön
ich fühle mich also ich bin habe schon
voll viel abgenommen
also alle gerät ganz ehrlich mal
unabhängig davon ob du jetzt wirklich
abgenommen hast oder nicht oder viel
abgenommen hast warum wird uns sowas
gezeigt womit haben wir das eigentlich
verdient weil wir in unseren vorherigen
leben schlechte menschen mein körper es
schon ansehbar denn als ich angefangen
habe war hier schwabl da schwabl ok
sebastian brück
ich muss nicht an der stelle wirklich
zurückhaltend heute war ich bin
tatsächlich im echten leben jemand der
sehr gerne mal ein spruch drückt den
eigenen kumpels oder auch aller
deutlichkeit kennengelernt habe und ich
versuche im internet immer ein bisschen
besseres bild abzugeben und nicht
gemeint zu sein aber das ist so eine
steilvorlage leitete es wird mich
wirklich den fingerspitzen aber jetzt
bin ich bin super schlank da sieht man
ja auch wohler so angeregt wird sich
jetzt immer mein total sexy aber ich
sage mal so naja natürlich genau das
aber ganz ehrlich auch leute die arme
frau also die von sich selbst so mit
sowas um die ecke kommt wenn i mit rtl 2
dreht ich werde mit euch das geht so auf
irgend so ein produzent von rtl2 aus
kanada aus köln oder berlin oder wird er
wahr ist in irgendeinem kaff in keine
ahnung wo timbuktu irgendwo in
deutschland gefahren und dann haben sie
diese alte frau belagert dass sie von
family stories erzählt dass sie sexy
sein
das ist so falsch ganz ehrlich
dafür habe ich mich nicht angemeldet als
ich diesen youtube-kanal erstellt habe
was was war es überhaupt zulassen wer
wegkommt sexy annegret teil kommt sechs
jahre alter mann mit ihrem sexy cora war
nein einfach nein nein das ist einfach
moralisch falsch das ist so falsch auf
so vielen verschiedenen eben das ist
schon moralisch falsch leute das sind
auf einer moralisch falsch stufe mit
seinem dreijährigen kind alkohol geben
und jetzt bin ich
ich kann mir sagen was man dazu sagen
muss es gibt ja ein sehr berühmtes zitat
von der berühmten deutschen politikerin
was perfekt auf diese situation passt
angela merkel was sollen wir dazu sagen
daniel und wolle die haben keine ahnung
ich fühle mich gut und sie sollen die
klappe halten und damit ist für annegret
auch klar jetzt kann die männer jagten
losgehen
ich werde mal ganz ehrlich mit euch
leute was mir durch den kopf geht ich
frage mich persönlich hat da schon mal
jemand rtl2 auf schmerzensgeld verklagt
auf schadensersatz für den psychischen
schaden für den emotionalen schaden als
schlimm genug dass die schon in ihrem
wohnzimmer so einen film gibt also dass
das ist schon nicht normal und ich kann
mir auch nicht vorstellen dass ein
normaler mensch mit einer normalen
selbstreflektion so etwas machen würde
aber jetzt geht sie auch noch auf
männerjagd misst mainz ob damit
gescheitert ist finde ich denke ja in
einem chat portal werden die heißesten
typen unter die lupe genommen ich wissen
was mich frage leute ich frage mich wie
geht es dem typen der diese sachen
kommentiert okay weil ich bin ja quasi
nur der der die bereits kommentierten
sachen beim noch mal kommentiert aber
erst war sie der erste er sieht dieses
rohr bildmaterial und muss dann dazu die
story nacherzählen ok kümmert sich
irgendjemand um den man kann da
vielleicht mal eine anrufen fragen wie
es ihm geht vielleicht den therapie
schicken alle sind sie schnell einig sie
sind in minna paradies leckerbissen
wohin die maus auch klickt
alter das ist wirklich hart choristes
ist das ist tatsächlich auch körperlich
anstrengend sich dieses video reinziehen
ob ihr wisst ihr was heute scheiße ich
halte was gemein dass es ok dieses video
ist wie ein unfall wie ein
verkehrsunfall
ja man weiß man sollte nicht hinschauen
aber man schaut sich trotzdem ganz ich
weiß nicht warum ich mir vorher nicht
darauf hingewiesen habe dass ist
definitiv heute schon längst an der zeit
gewesen schutz aufs land zu ziehen weil
er jetzt als typ muss top aussehen top
job top klasse wenn möglich mit auto da
sie ja auch nicht mehr so richtig so
schnell laufen kann also annegret werden
ab so das model also der muss auf jeden
fall schon in der men's health gewesen
sein millionär muss man natürlich auch
sei gebildet ganz klar und dann auf der
anderen seite so er braucht ein auto
weil sie nicht mehr laufen kann
vielleicht ein bisschen bisschen
realistischere maßstäbe ansetzen gibt
mich nicht mit jedem zufrieden
deswegen werden die potenziellen bett
gefährten auch genauestens beäugt und
schnell haben die mädels einen favoriten
also ganz ehrlich leute denn die frau
hat doch das ist doch eine oma oder als
mann der hat doch enkel oder nicht jetzt
ist sie allen ernstes auf rtl2 und sucht
einen weggefährten ich muss mich
korrigieren leute wir haben gerade eine
neue stufe von moralisch falsch erreicht
eben was noch kleinen kindern alkohol
geben
jetzt sind wir schon optisch stufe
schwangere die treppe runterschubsen das
ist wirklich hardcore
ungepflegt allegri ist rock verliebt ist
sorry aber hey alter dass sowas
überhaupt im deutschen fernsehen laufen
darf es ist einfach so leute also es ist
einfach wie ein verkehrsunfall
das ist aber das einzig wahre das also
kriegt man dazu sagen kann es ist wie
ein fucking verkehrsunfall
denn ja schon ganz süß und auch
überhaupt okay aber ich muss ganz kurz
fällt noch ein bisschen die kritik
zurück nehmen also gerade eben dachte
ich mir so sie will wirklich so tom
cruise oder bei tom cruise ist bei
scientology das bisher schon keine
ahnung brad pitt oder so haben aber der
ist ja schon ein bisschen realistischer
[Musik]
feuer spucken ja das passt doch erst
kürzlich hat er an diese mich erinnert
ich fühle mich die hat irgendwas
gemeinsam mit frau mal zahlen aber kenne
frau mahlzahn aus jim knopf jim knopf
und seinen freund luca ist so wie ich
jetzt mal mein lebenspartner mehr
vorstellen
okay dann muss aber dazu schon sagen
also die bilder die sind schon relativ
die diesen schon gut gemacht also er ist
er sehr gut in szene gesetzt ich
persönlich fühle mich jetzt auch schon
auf jeden fall angezogen von ihm sagt
maria dieser kaffeetrinker welcher
normale mensch machten einer kaffeetasse
was soll das aussagen hey ich hab eine
tasse nämlich weil ich eine tasse hab
ich aber noch eine hand trug ich kann
die hand oder benutzen die hand
funktioniert noch ich habe eine
funktionierende hand und eine tasse
nämlich papa sitzt er jetzt nicht mal
den den anschreiben oder überhaupt
sieger in meine anfragen sagt der seite
warum jetzt schon lange gebraucht bis
herauskam
das war ein ganz schöner kampf wir sind
ja ich will nicht so gemeinsam diesem
jesus leute aber ich merke sowieso die
gemeinheit aus mir raus also sie kann
gerade in wirklich ein bisschen
besorgten also wird
den satz kosten kommen soll ist die
anschreiben muss ich erstmal andere
fotos haben weil ich sehr ganz anders
aus und um 6 ich weiß nicht ob es gerade
gehört habt heute aber der hintergrund
dafür dass sie sich jetzt auf einmal
sehr sexy findet ist dass sie ein kilo
abgenommen hat also sie hat ein kilo
abgenommen
1 von 431 gesagt getan
schließlich will keiner die katze im
sack kaufen also vorhang auf für
sexbombe annegret okay leute wissen was
meine stimmung wechselt gerade leute
meine stimmung wechselt gerade von bin
sauer dass es sowas gibt zu ich habe
tatsächlich mit mit den leuten die in
diesen videos auftauchen sehen wir doch
ganz ehrlich leute oftmals sind die
leute die bei sowas mitmachen klingt
jetzt hartaberfair geistig nicht ganz
entwickelt längst nicht alle aber viele
wirken so als hätten sie nicht ganz
verstanden was rtl 2 damit ihm machen
will und lassen sich halt komplett
blamieren und das ist jetzt quasi auf
wie man es eigentlich schon falsch war
noch mal eine andere stufe an falscher
drauf macht jetzt die fotos und schluss
ist
[Musik]
neben den in den in den stopp stopp ich
habe keinen bock mehr auf den boden
bringen also leute wirklich eine folge
dieser mit einem lachenden und einem
weinenden auge gleichzeitig sieht wo er
eigentlich ihre mit zwei weinenden augen
ich kann es nicht fassen wie das geld
angespart werden sollte es jetzt da
draußen durch dass ich noch eine einzige
person geben die noch nicht genug von
deutschland ev hat habe ich euch hier
eine playlist mit meinen ganzen tvr
actions verlinkt schaut euch gerne an
und bitte schicken beim nächsten mal
weniger schlimme videos bitte